l'ambassadeur au nom de mes collègues je
suis très heureux de vous accueillir au
Palais du Luxembourg et je vous remercie
d'avoir accepté de venir de vendre notre
commission comme il est tradition pour
les ambassadeurs dont les pays reçoivent
la présidence nous présenter les
priorités de la présidente espagnole du
Conseil de l'Union européenne en effet
l'Espagne a repris le relais de la Suède
et assume la présidence du Conseil de
l'Union européenne depuis le 1er juillet
il s'agit de la cinquième président
assurée par votre pays c'est aussi la
première du trio de président qu'il
forme sur 18 mois avec la Belgique et la
Hongrie
le calendrier de votre président ça a
été quelque peu perturbé par l'annonce
par le Premier ministre socialiste Pedro
Sanchez d'élections générales anticipées
qui se tiendront le 23 juillet prochain
alors que le Parti Populaire a remporté
plusieurs élections municipales et
régionales récemment que le parti
d'extrême droite Vox progresse dans les
sondages vous nous direz certainement
quel impact pour avoir ses élections et
un éventuel changement de gouvernement
sur la présidence espagnole
par ailleurs votre président se déroule
dans un contexte de très grande
incertitude avec le conflit en Ukraine
la situation économique en Europe et la
crise énergétique
face à ces défis la devise qui a été
choisie par votre pays l'Europe plus
proche traduit une ambition de proximité
humaine politique et institutionnelle
que notre commission partage et depuis
longtemps
les quatre grandes priorités de la
présidente espagnole portent sur
réindustrialiser l'Union européenne est
garantir son autonomie stratégique
ouverte faire progresser la transition
écologique et l'adaptation
environnementale
promouvoir une plus grande justice
sociale et économique et renforcer
l'unité européenne
nous savons que votre président sera
très attentive non seulement à assurer
la sécurité en Europe qui est le besoin
fondamental avec la guerre menée par la
Russie contre l'Ukraine mais aussi à y
conforter la croissance la
réindustrialisation de l'Europe est
l'une de vos priorités en même temps que
les transitions écologiques et
énergétiques nous sommes toutefois
inquiets ici au Sénat de l'articulation
entre la transition écologique prévue
par le Green Deal et la croissance
notamment en matière agricole plusieurs
évaluations estiment en effet que le
verdissement de l'agriculture va
entraîner un recul sensible de la
production de 5 à 20% ce qui met en
péril l'autonomie alimentaire européenne
dont la guerre en Ukraine montre
l'importance
l'Espagne qui est aussi un grand pays
agricole en tant que faire de la
souveraineté alimentaire une priorité
pour l'Union européenne qu'en est-il à
cet égard des risques notamment sur
l'élevage européen que pourrait faire
peser l'accord commercial de l'Union
européenne avec les pays du Mercosur
dont l'Espagne a fait une priorité et
c'est peut-être une divergence qui sur
laquelle il faudra s'attarder
nous relevons aussi l'ambition espagnole
de réindustrialiser l'Europe pour
garantir son autonomie stratégique
c'est une ambition que nous partageons
aussi
votre pays s'engage aussi à promouvoir
une plus grande justice sociale à
économique sur ce sujet auquel la France
est très attachée pourriez-vous nous
préciser quelles options la présidence
espagnole envisage-t-elle
enfin la présidente espagnole entend
mettre l'accent sur l'unité de l'Europe
des discussions difficiles devraient
commencer sous votre président notamment
sur la réforme de la gouvernance
économique le budget européen et la
réforme du cadre financier pluriannuel
ou encore sur une éventuelle ouverture
des négociations d'adhésion à l'Ukraine
à la Moldavie et peut-être à la Géorgie
nous avons aussi noté que la Hongrie et
la Pologne n'ont pas souscrit aux
conclusions du Conseil européen sur le
sujet migratoire qui est pourtant
prioritaire aussi pour l'Espagne pays de
première entrée
je ne sera pas chose aisé de préserver
l'unité des Européens sur ces dossiers
qui sont on le sait très sensible
car comme là dit l'écrivain espagnol
servante deux moineaux sur le même épi
ne sont pas longtemps Unis
nous comptons que beaucoup sur l'Espagne
pour préserver l'unité des Européens
face à ces défis et Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur je vous cède la parole
merci
tout le monde et Mesdames et sénatrices
monsieur le sénateur chère membre de la
Commission
c'est toujours un plaisir
en tant qu'ambassade d'Espagne en France
des comparaître dans cette chambre qui
est l'un des piliers du pouvoir
législatif en France et un symbole de la
souveraineté populaire et aussi de
l'importance des territoires
je voudrais vous remercier monsieur le
Président de m'avoir appelé
auprès de la Commission à l'occasion
d'être la présidence espagnole
dans mon intervention que
je voudrais complète je vais essayer
d'aborder les priorités de la préférence
espagnole
tout d'abord je voudrais remercier
d'apprécier en sortante la Suède pour
leur magnifique travail Paris comme à
Bruxelles pendant ces 6 derniers mois
comme vous savez dit monsieur le
Président avant de rentrer dans le vif
du sujet et comme vous le savez bien
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrice le
président du gouvernement espagnol a
convoqué des solutions législatives pour
le 23 juillet
comme il a dit lui-même et comme
monsieur le Président du Conseil Saint
Michel a confirmé lors de sa récente
visite à Madrid le fait d'avoir une
période électorale en pleine présidence
ne va pas s'enterrer le programme et les
priorités ni par ailleurs les compromis
de l'Espagne des serpents politiques ces
diplomates et fonctionnaires Toulouse
nous allons mettre tout notre mieux pour
assurer le succès de la présidence
c'est un engagement en tant que qu'un
grand pays membre avec l'Union
européenne et ses substitutions et cette
présence est bien entendu une question
d'état qui dépasse l'écrivais sa
conjoncture
que vous avez dit la présidence du
conseil pour la cinquième fois depuis
notre section en 1986 je dirais que les
précédents constitué une histoire de
succès et j'espère que celle-ci ne sera
aussi chaque président a connu ce défi
l'Espagne comme la Suède avant elle et
la France auparavant
l'assume dans ce moment clé de
l'histoire de l'Europe les circonstances
actuelles inattendus il y a peu ont
accélérer certains de bas qui étaient
déjà sur la table qui porte
essentiellement sur la place que doit
occuper dans un monde en transformation
et qui nous ferons parler dans les six
mois à venir de l'Ukraine de l'autonomie
stratégique de l'unité face au menace de
renforcement de la démocratie des
transitions énergétiques et des
nouvelles géopolitiques nous avons
devant nous encore
plus de filles qu'avant interne et
externe mais avec la moitié des temples
peut-être pour le faire face
la bonne nouvelle et que nous avons
gagné en détermination et ses sentiments
puissants et la force qui peut nous
aider à changer la donne et à contribuer
modestement à la grandeur de l'Europe
il avait vu ce que le gouvernement
espagnol a choisi pour ses présidents
comme vous savez mentionné l'Europe plus
proche et européen c'est et monsieur le
Président Mesdames Messieurs Laurence
sans doute à poussière interprétation
mais l'idée que nous voulons faire
passer c'est que nous vivons à un moment
où les rapprochements que ce soit
eux-mêmes politique ou institutionnelle
et fondamental pour assurer nos citoyens
face à l'incertitude et pour porter le
projet européen plus loin dans son
esprit et dans sa réalité
bien entendu la précision ne peut tout
mais je crois modestement que l'Espagne
a la force de la crédibilité la capacité
à un Europe pour travailler pour
favoriser des accords des consensus et
pour permettre l'Europe d'avancer
en ce qui concerne les priorités
mesdames messieurs quand on parle
priorité évidemment
c'est toujours une façon de diviser les
grands sujets de la présidence je vais
libérer les priorités affichées de cette
précision mais c'est en Suisse si vous
me présenter j'ai parlé russe de
certains sujets qui sont tout aussi
importants voire plus quand il faut
partir des domaines les plus concrets
et plus
marqué de cette présidence et la
situation actuelle
on ne peut pas laisser parler de
l'Ukraine de l'application de l'acide du
pacte de stabilité de la gouvernance du
futur de l'Europe et aussi de son
élargissement
cela dit nos priorités que vous pouvez
consulter sur les pronom officiel de la
pression 4 se résumé en 6 d'abord la
reine de civilisation de l'Europe avec
la garantie en même temps d'une
autonomie stratégique ouverte celui de
la destructure est un sujet qui occupe
préoccupe l'Espagne comme la France
aussi qui mène depuis le temps il va
être contre les Décines d'austérisation
de la délocalisation et la perte de
compétitivité
l'Espagne est en même temps conscient
que l'ouverture internationale constitué
l'un des principaux leviers des progrès
celle-ci a généré de la prospérité mais
cela a eu également des conséquences
qu'on pourrait conseiller négatif comme
les inégalités en raison de la
concurrence ça limite
dans ce domaine nous devons penser à des
situations comme le phénomène de la
délocalisation qui a fait perdre
l'Europe des sandwichs dans des certains
statistiques qui ont eu des conséquences
sérieuses sur l'ensemble de notre chute
tueur économique ainsi que sur notre
coecution territoriale en tant que
sénateur sénatrice je suis sûr que vous
connaissez mieux que personne cette
problématique ces situations génèrent
une dépendance excessive de l'Europe par
rapport à d'autres acteurs
internationaux dans des domaines
essentiels comme la santé l'énergie la
technologie numérique ou l'alimentation
afin d'affronter des défis destructifs
la présidence espagnole en temps
promouvoir les dossiers visant
revitaliser les industries stratégiques
en Europe dans cet esprit également nous
renforcerons notre collaboration avec
des pays tiers toujours avec le but en
tête de combiner l'autonomie stratégique
et l'ouverture et stratégique
l'Espagne préconisément européenne à
l'autonomie stratégique ouverte centrée
sur le domaine qui ont une incidence sur
le quotidien des citoyens c'est un vaste
sujet qui a des implications économiques
industrielles commerciales géopolitique
il s'agit de consolider notre marché
d'élargies leur rayonnement économique
commercial de l'Europe par la vieille de
notre politique étrangère et commerciale
à travers une politique économique
commerciale ouverte dont je parlais tout
à l'heure la deuxième priorité c'est la
transition écologique et la mise à jour
environ lamental
pour la pression espagnole la tension au
changement climatique est à la fois un
devoir moral une obligation légale nous
conseillons qu'il est aussi une
opportunité une opportunité de
croissance et de progrès qui réduira la
dépendance énergétique ainsi que la
facture électrique les importations des
combustibles fossiles tout en rendant
les entreprises plus compétitifs et en
créant plus d'ampleur
on vise à réduire le prix de
l'électricité à un cheval la réforme du
marché électrique initié pendant les
précédentes précédentes et en deux temps
déstabiliter le système qui s'est révélé
extrêmement volubile depuis le début de
la guerre du crâne 2022 l'Espagne
promouvoir les dossiers liés au paquet
feed for fifty-five paquet de gaz et
d'hydrogène réglement d'efficacité
énergétique initiative de réduction des
déchets et microplastiques des signes
des produits réparables et générations
de combustibles écologiques nous
soutenions aussi l'agenda vert à notre
l'Espagne encouragea l'application des
objectifs de développement soutenable
des nations se dit ainsi qu'une reprise
socio-économique juste soutenable pour
tous
il est question en somme madame monsieur
d'une réforme des systèmes énergétique
européen capable de réduire ces bulles
de réhabilité
les troisièmes piliers de notre
présidence va être la justice sociale et
économique les pays social un effet la
pression espagnole vénéra la promotion
d'une plus grande justice sociale
économique visa ce qu'il a richesse et
la raie profite à tous les citoyens tout
en combinant une économie plus
compétitive avec une dimension sociale
plus juste et solidaire pour ce faire il
faut une révision adéquate du cadre
financier plus annuel
2021-2027 sur lequel je reviendrai après
dans ce but nous saisirons de faire
progresser les initiatives et les
Soviétiques fixés par le plan d'action
du pays européen des droits sociaux
Fabrice à la participation dans la
définition des questions d'emplois et
sociales du semestre européen
la présidence que consacrera également à
l'extension des droits des travailleurs
et au soutiennent d'autres initiatives
que les soins sanitaires de longue durée
la protection des personnes sans-abris
la création de la carte européenne pour
les personnes handicapées ou la
consolidation de la réglementation
concernant le revenu minimum
dans ce bain 4 la présidence viscérale
la création de nouvelles opportunités
pour la jeunesse la présidence espagnole
viscère a également renforcer l'Europe
de la santé tout en promouvant les soins
primaires des traitements chroniques et
chez l'Européen ainsi que l'encourageant
le débat sur la santé mentale dans
l'Union sans oublier la santé animale et
environnementale la présidence espagnole
mettra aussi l'accent sur la convention
territoriale
en particulier le problème lié au des
peuplements et le domaine des sommes
rurales et maritimes finalement la
quatrième priorité
ça sera le renforcement que vous avez
dit le lutter de l'unité européenne
monsieur le Président Monsieur mesdames
messieurs pour faire face au contexte
que nous vivons l'Europe doit renforcer
son unité ceci va notamment pour l'Union
européenne mais aussi pour les pays amis
et associés qui n'en font pas partie à
part entière dans un contexte nous la
reconnaissons l'importance de
l'initiative française concernant la
communauté politique européenne car le
renfort de mécanismes de lutter ne doit
pas porter seulement sur l'intégration
notre force est dans les débat qui vise
à plus d'unité malgré les différences
ceci comporte une mise en valeur de nos
principes tout en renforçant la
protection de l'État de droit et les
fondements de la démocratie
plus concrètement nous essayons de
compléter le pâté migration et acide
dont je parlais à l'instant et de
renforcer l'espace de liberté de
sécurité de justice tant dans la
dimension intérieure qui est dans la
dimension extérieure nous travaillerons
aussi pour la promotion d'une Europe des
citoyens et dans l'élargissement de leur
moyen de participation c'est le moment
de rapprocher comme j'avais dit avant
d'un point de vue plus technique
l'Espagne préconise approfondissement du
marché intérieur accumulation de l'Union
bancaire et le développement d'un agenda
des finances soutenables également nous
travaillerons pour la consolidation des
instruments comment comme le font
affichées de cette précédente
permettez-moi quelques minutes de plus
pour aborder certains sujets qui sont
cruciaux pour l'avenir immédiat de
l'Union européenne et qui font référence
à des aspects fondamentaux de notre vie
politique communautaire et de la vie des
citoyens
en premier lieu l'Ukraine
et en parlant de l'Ukraine on touche à
plusieurs matières en même temps on peut
parler l'autonomie stratégique de
l'énergie des conséquences économiques
mais surtout je crois qu'on doit parler
d'abord des grands principes et du
soutien à l'Ukraine pendant ces visites
le premier juillet le président du
gouvernement espagnol c'était les
premiers actes de la présidente
espagnole s'est entretenu avec le
patience Linski et s'est adressé au
parlementaire il a clairement dit que
nous soutiendrions l'Ukraine jusqu'au
bout jusqu'à la victoire il allait aussi
que seulement l'uprennent peut fixer les
conditions et les sessions d'une
éventuelle négociation de paix avec la
Russie
le plan de 10 points présentés par le
président selenski et notre document
dévast pour acheminer le moment venu le
négociation
dans cet esprit la présidence espagnole
va contribuer à l'action commune de
l'Union européenne face à la région
illégale de la Russie après doublant les
efforts avec des États tiers pour
garantir le soutien international
nécessaire à nos sociétés
toujours délicats de l'élargissement
désormais les craint comme la Moldavie
sont des pays candidats et signal dans
ce point le rapport annuel de la
Commission à ses propositions des pays
candidats qui va être présenté le mois
d'octobre
notre idée c'est d'impulser les
conclusions du Conseil l'Union
européenne sur l'élargissement sous une
perspective réaliste pour les pays
candidats
nous essayons dans la mesure du possible
de convoquer des conférences
intergouvernementales avec ces pays-là
pour aborder les diverses chapitres
négociations et pour favoriser d'une
façon à notre ouverture de négociation
avec l'Ukraine et la Moldavie
mais on devra attendre le rapport de la
Commission
cela fait ça on ne doit pas oublier les
Balkans aussi un tour dont l'importance
géopolitique et des coécutions de
l'Europe dans un moment pas facile non
plus vu leur dernier à ses vêtements ne
doit pas être négligé
ceci est un bon exemple de
l'accélération de ces cercles de la
politique par la force de faire
en parlant de l'élargissement on peut
pas parler n'est pas parler du futur de
l'Europe la présidence cherche
approfondir le débat sur le nommé classe
passerelle pour éteindre les recours à
la majorité qualifiée que ce soit dans
les affaires de PESC comme d'autres
politiques européennes clés fiscale cela
fait partie d'un autre plus large qui
sort qui portait sur la dynamisation des
processus de prise de décision de
l'Union européenne et sa capacité à
réponse face à des crises futures nous
ferons aussi le suivi de tous les
initiatives qui portent sur la
conférence sur le futur de l'Europe et
la réforme des crédits
ensuite monsieur le Président je voulais
parler brièvement de sujets de la
migration et la cils il s'agit sans
doute un sujet aussi important que
délicat qui conditionne énormément le
débat politique en Europe les positions
de cet homme sont souvent diverses
parfois controversé à la présidence donc
de mettre du sien pour les rapprocher
afin d'atteindre une solution à cette
table pour tous
beaucoup de chemin a été faits pendant
la présidence sortante la présidence
suédoise l'essentiel a déjà été négocié
grâce au bon travail de nos amis il
s'agit de trouver en somme un point
d'équilibre dans l'ensemble de la
politique migratoire de l'Union
européenne et on travaille sur deux
plans différents à l'intérieur on
cherche établir un dispositif légal de
gestion migratoire et frontalière sous
la prémisse en fonctionnement avec quoi
du système commun européen d'acide à
l'extérieur on cherche aussi une
politique extérieure d'une européenne
qui vise le contrôle de flux migratoires
en coopération avec les principales pays
d'origine et des transit
la dimension intérieure cherche
l'équilibre entre deux principes
fondamentaux la responsabilité et la
solidarité
une feuille de route a été accordée par
le Parlement européen et les différentes
précédentes afin d'attendre les pacte
avant la fin de législatures européennes
tous ceux sur trois piliers législatives
le règlement de gestion de la cils et la
migration qui consacre un mécanisme de
solidarité obligatoire et stable et
prédictive le règlement de la procédure
d'acide qui enfera la question et
punaise de la procédure obligatoire à la
frontière et le concept de pays tiers
sur et finalement le règlement des
crises qui encore en discussion au
Conseil
la dimension extérieure de sa part
comporte un essor de la diplomatie
migratoire communautaire la précision de
la Commission se rendu le mois dernier
en Tunisie la première ministre
italienne
route pendant les dernières années
l'action extérieure des diverses agences
impliquées c'est des Frontex nous savons
réussi à concrétiser le soutien
financier et pendant les deux dernières
présidents chèque suédoise nous savons
avancer dans la gestion de Christ
notamment moyennant des plans d'action
de la part de la Commission
un autre sujet important c'est
évidemment le sujet de l'énergie
en matière d'énergie je voudrais
souligner trois priorités la première
achever une énergie sur durable et
abordable la deuxième la déclination
énergétique du principe de l'autonomie
stratégique ouverte et la troisième la
décarbonisation de l'économie
pour le premier point nous souhaitons
garantir une énergie sur à travers trois
principes des acteurs promouvoir
l'investissement dans les énergies
renouvelables garantir la
provisionnement au stockage gestion de
la demande marché de capacité et
orienter les prix de l'électricité vers
la moyenne des coûts de production
nous ne pouvons pas remplacer une
dépendance celle du pétrole du gaz par
d'autres dépendances celle des matières
premières critiques pour la transition
énergétique telle que les nickels
là-dessus selon l'orientation générale
établie des 30 juin nous voulons
clôturer avec la fin de l'année la
critical romantidalecte règlement sur
les matières premières critiques
troisièmement ce qui concerne la
décarbonisation nous envisagions
d'achever dans notre précédente le
paquet hydrogène et gaz digestif et
règlement qui fait partie du paquety
five justement à l'objectif 55 qui
représente les fondements du
développement de l'hydrogène et le rôle
du gaz naturel dans l'économie
européenne pour la prochaine décennie
à notre sujet c'est le sujet de la
gouvernance et cadre financier plus à
Noël
monsieur le Président dans le domaine
économique l'Espagne souhaite poursuivre
les travaux qui ont pour but une
gouvernance économique et financière
mieux adapter au besoin des États
membres et en renforcement des liens
commerciaux avec des partenaires
stratégiques donc par exemple l'Amérique
latine les dossiers européens en cours
de discussion définiront les cadres
économiques et budgétaires de l'Union
européenne au cours des 10 prochains
amis les dossiers en cours certainement
complexe d'un point de vue technique
sont le suivant d'abord la gouvernance
économique la révision du parti
stabilité et des croissances et déjà
bien entamé le mandat établit que la
corde doit prendre place avant la fin de
l'année 2023
il est donc fondamental d'aboutir à
l'accord sur la communication de la
Commission européenne de novembre 2022
qui propose des orientations sur la
réforme de la gouvernance économique de
l'Union européenne
l'objectif de cette réforme d'obtenir un
mécanisme et d'évaluation de
l'endettement des États membres plus
simple plus transparent et plus efficace
il est aussi important de rendre
compatible de seulement essentiel de la
stratégie européenne d'un côté les États
membres doivent aborder les réformes
nécessaires pour aboutir à niveau
d'endettement public soutenable en même
temps ils doivent avoir une marge
fiscale suffisante qui leur permettra de
ralisser les investissements
incontournables dans la stratégie de
transition énergétique et de
souveraineté industriels qui concerne
l'ensemble l'Union européenne
la révision de la gouvernance économique
attendait central de notre précédente
un autre point c'est leur vie à mi-court
du cadre financier plus annuel 2021 2027
cette revue du budget de l'Union
européenne est nécessaire pour aborder
les dossiers des transformations
industrielle énergétiques numériques qui
font partie des sociétés prioritaires de
l'Union européenne la Commission
européenne a transformé sa proposition
initiale d'enfance souveraineté par un
instrument nommé et step
les objectifs essentiel de cet éventuel
nouvelle capacité financière serait de
renforcer l'autonomie stratégique de
l'Union européenne et de réduire ça
dépend dans ces termes dans des domaines
cruciaux le Conseil discutera la
promotion de projets européens dans le
domaine des bactéries de l'hydrogène des
semi-conducteurs et des matières
premières rares il y aura aussi facilité
Ukraine qui sera discuté dans cette
unveloppe et reste définir d'autres
points et spécifiques
je voudrais aussi faire un petit point
sur la politique de concurrence et de
contrôle des CFDT il s'agit d'un dossier
où la Commission européenne est
compétente mais la pression espagnole
accompagnera le devant au sein du
conseil il s'agit de faciliter le
déploiement efficace du projet européen
d'intérêt sauce et spécial tout en
respectant les règles du marché unique
en tout cas l'Espagne est attaché à
faire avancer ce dossiers d'une
importance incontournable parce qu'il
s'agit de rendre compatible une
flexibilité accrue des chefs d'État avec
le maintien de l'intégrité du marché
unique
politique commerciale très rapidement
les rédactions commerciales de l'Union
européenne avec le reste du monde sont
une pièce fondamentale de l'autonomie et
stratégique ouverte quand on dit ouverte
on parle de ça et de la diffusion des
valeurs européennes chez les principaux
partenaires commerciaux la présidence
espagnole du Conseil souhaite dynamiser
les discussions et accélérer l'adoption
des traités des libre-échange en cours
de discussion avec l'Australie et l'Inde
et trouver un des solutions définitives
aux différents avaient laissé tata Unis
mais c'est avec nos partenaires de la
mairie de latine quel Espagne souhaite
accélérer les dossiers en cours il
s'agit d'un sous-continent qui est
appelé à jouer un rôle fondamental dans
les chaînes d'approvisionnement des
matières essentielles pour la transition
énergétique de l'Union européenne
la profondissement de relations avec la
mairie de latine doit être un objectif
stratégique des premières pour l'Union
européenne on partage des valeurs on
partage la culture même les langues
ainsi nous souhaitons compléter les
démarches de signatures ratification de
nouveaux textes des modernisation des
accords d'associations
umexique et où est Chili
je voudrais faire une mention à spéciale
l'accord de principe date de 2019
suscita des doutes quand on s'engagement
environnementaux de certains pays la
Commission européenne présente un membre
de l'Union européenne et au Pays du
mercusur avril 2023 il y a quelques mois
un instrument conjoint additionnel qui
vit sa renforcer les engagements de tous
les sénateurs en matière
environnementale et à permettre
l'acceptation de l'accord dans certains
États membres qui se montrent réticents
dont la France
ce document détaille les engagements en
matière de lutte contre la déforestation
des droits des travailleurs et de
l'accord de Paris
il inclut certes pas des sanctions en
matière de préférence commerciale
à ce stade madame monsieur le pays de
Mercosur n'ont pas encore réagi à cette
proposition
on attend la présidence espagnole serait
atteint le reposte réponse pour annoncer
à l'accord où les possibilités de
l'accord pendant le sommet US et là qui
s'éteindra à Bruxelles les 17 et 18
juillet prochain
une fois la proposition des pays
sud-américains sera reçu c'est
impossible d'établir un nouveau
calendrier de négociation sous pression
espagnole dans tous les cas l'Espagne à
l'intention de donner un élan définitif
à ces dossiers car il est important d'un
point de vue économique et commercial
mais fondamental d'un point de vue GF
statistique
là où l'Union européenne ne s'est pas
présente d'autres puissances parfois à
des valeurs différentes en notre le
seront
finalement pour la culture vous l'avez
mentionné
d'une européenne vous le savez bien les
premiers producteur mondial des denrées
alimentaires et à une grande
responsabilité en matière de sécurité
alimentaire
associée à la réalisation des
Soviétiques et développement durable la
présidence espagnole poursuivra le
travail fait contre les distorsion du
marché découlant d'événements récents
nos priorités à l'agriculture sont
première travailler sur l'automobile
stratégique ouverte et système avant
alimentaire qui est l'un de quatre
domaines du projet Open stratégie
autonomie
2 estimé promouvoir les technologies au
sein de secteurs alimentaires permettant
à l'agriculture du 21e siècle de
produire avec moins d'un train et de
s'adapter aux défis du changement
climatique en réduisant notre
indépendance à l'égard des importations
3 garantir et améliorer la sécurité
alimentaire la santé et la sécurité et
la protection de l'environnement
plusieurs dossiers législatifs relèvent
de ce domaine tels que le bien-être
animal utilisation durable les produits
phytopharmaceutiques etc 4 souligner
l'importance du milieu rural en tant que
colonne vertébrale sociale territoriale
et économique de l'Union européenne et
l'importance de la politique agricole
commune à ce but et 5 donner de la
visibilité au monde rural en travaillant
sur la vision à long terme des sons
rurales européennes lors de la
conférence de haut niveau chez une
future ruralias sur ce sujet n'est ce
pas comment prier agricole tels que la
France nous connaissons bien
l'importance du milieu rural et les
conséquences de la cohésion territoriale
monsieur le Président Mesdames Messieurs
je vous prie de m'inscrire pour avoir
dépassé peut-être le temps mais il m'a
semblé important d'aborder les
différents sujets avec un peu de
perspective et une certaine un certain
approfondissement je suis à votre
disposition et je vous remercie merci
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur c'était très
précis je crois
vous avez évoqué tous les sujets que que
j'avais
embarqué dans mon propos
introductif mais néanmoins je pense que
mes collègues vont prendre la parole
parce que
ils ont des choses à dire alors le
premier qui l'a demandé c'est que
l'autre cairn puis Didier marie puis
Pascal
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur pour votre
présentation
très complète
il y a un point sur lequel je j'aimerais
revenir c'est au niveau du deuxième
objectif la transition écologique et
notamment la partie énergétique
à aucun moment vous avez vous n'avez
évoqué effectivement un principe enfin
une technologie qui tient à cœur aux
Français mais qui risque effectivement
de porter des bas
lors des différents sommets des
prochains sommets je veux parler de
l'énergie nucléaire puisque vous avez
parlé d'une énergie sûre durable et
abordable et de la décarbonation la
carbonisation pardon
quel est est-ce que la position de votre
pays
risque de changer et surtout quelle est
la position actuelle de votre pays et
puis j'avais une deuxième question en ce
qui concerne l'élargissement
quel est votre position par rapport à la
Géorgie
merci pour vos propos extrêmement précis
et particulièrement intéressant
moi je me félicite d'une part des
orientations que vous avez mentionné
extrêmement couragants sur les aspects
sociaux et environnementaux de la
présidence espagnole et vos priorités
sur la justice fiscale et la lutte
contre l'évasion fiscale j'aurais trois
points
à évoquer le premier vous n'avez pas
parlé vous n'avez pas mentionné
la fin des négociations sur la directive
concernant le devoir de vigilance des
multinationales et des grandes
entreprises
logiquement on arrive au bout de la
négociation et c'est la présidente
espagnole qui devrait conclure celle-ci
donc je voudrais savoir quel est votre
position et dans quelle mesure vous
pensez aboutir deuxième
remarque vous avez parlé du cadre
financier pluriannuel
et de sa révision qui va intervenir
prochainement
la commission annonce des négociations
sur la mise en oeuvre une taxe à 0,5
points sur les profits des grandes multi
nationales
qui s'ajouterait
aux produits de la taxe carbone et des
Ets ce qui porterait un total de
ressources nouvelles propres à 36
milliards d'euros permettant semble-t-il
de rembourser la dette contractée
pendant la crise covid
ceci étant j'ai le sentiment qu'on n'a
pas suffisamment de ressources propres
et je voudrais connaître la position de
la présidente espagnole sur les
négociations qui vont s'ouvrir sur ce
sujet et sur la perspective d'autres
ressources propres qui ont déjà été
évoquées notamment vraiment une taxe sur
les transactions financières
troisième point vous avez abondamment
parlé du Mercosur et des difficultés que
nous rencontrions entre l'Union
européenne et notamment le Brésil
le round de négociation des 29 et 30
juin dernier a été annulé par les États
d'Amérique du Sud
une nouvelle rencontre est prévue
prochainement avec un sommet de chef
d'État le cas échéant
moi j'ai noté que Le président Lula
voulait revenir sur un certain nombre
des aspects de la négociation notamment
sur l'ouverture des marchés publics
brésiliens aux entreprises européennes
qu'il considèrent comme trop large ce
qui ré-ouvrirait la totalité de la
négociation et d'autre part vous avez
évoqué
l'Acte additionnel sur l'environnement
je soulignerai et vous l'avez dit que
cet acte n'est pas contraignant ce qui
inquiète grandement un bon nombre
de nos ressortissants
et je voudrais savoir si on pourrait par
le gouvernement d'abord et je voudrais
savoir si vous envisageriez si une reine
négociation était ouverte
d'intervenir sur ce sujet enfin dernier
point on a beaucoup évoqué aussi les
questions d'élargissement l'Espagne a
une position
particulière avec quelques autres
États membres à l'égard du Kosovo et je
voulais savoir si votre pays était prêt
à envisager la reconnaissance du Kosovo
dans le cadre de la politique de
l'élargissement qu'on mène dans les
balcons occidentaux on ne pourra pas
traiter le Kosovo comme
n'existant pas sur
ce segment européen je vous remercie
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur merci pour vos
propos alors moi j'ai des choses très
concrètes à voir avec vous
le premier ça concerne en fait le paquet
pharmaceutique
comme si européenne a présenté en avril
dernier et l'objectif c'est de faciliter
l'accès aux médicaments et vous savez
bien que nous vivons une pénurie assez
importante en France en corps davantage
il est certainement à des positions qui
ont été prises mais la Commission est
attardée à présenter ce paquet
pharmaceutique et il est peu probable en
fait qu'elle
ce paquet puisse être adopté avant la
fin de sa monture
mais comme nous c'est un sujet vraiment
important pour tous les citoyens
on voudrait en fait que la future
Commission bien sûr elle puisse le
reprendre mais on voudrait surtout
connaître la position de la présidence
espagnole et si la présidence espagnole
va plutôt pousser ce dossier ou ne pas
s'en occuper
et enfin un deuxième un deuxième sujet
qui concerne
en fait les travailleurs des plateformes
et nous étions allés avec le Président
je sais pas si tu étais on était allé à
Madrid puisque l'Espagne est avancé
complètement sur sur ce sur ce sujet et
qu'on voit bien que tout le monde n'est
pas n'est pas sur la même plan et en
France notamment c'est un peu compliqué
en revanche il y a des attentes aussi et
donc on voulait savoir si c'est un sujet
aussi que vous avez et je voudrais juste
compléter sur sur les accords notamment
avec le MERCOSUR
ou
nos agriculteurs sont vraiment
inquiet inquiet parce que il y a
plusieurs choses c'est à dire déjà sur
sur toutes les normes environnementales
que l'Union européenne impose à nos
agriculteurs et donc ne comprennent pas
qu'on puisse faire entrer des produits
qui ne sont pas au même norme c'est
d'ailleurs c'est très injuste donc
l'inquiétude est là et puis aussi la
politique agricole commune
indemniste de moins en moins les
agriculteurs ce qui pouvait permettre
d'accepter certains accords justement
parce qu'il y avait des compensations or
aujourd'hui finalement l'agriculture a
de moins en moins de subventions et ils
sont toujours liés en fait à un
verdissement trop dur trop fort trop
vite parce que les agriculteurs font
énormément d'efforts et pas seulement
depuis 5 ans ils ont changé leur
pratique depuis je dirais 30 ans chaque
fois ils ont évolué ils sont encore
prêts à le faire parce qu'ils vivent
aussi le changement climatique donc il
le laisse pas derrière
en revanche je pense que c'est un vrai
sujet il faut vraiment faire très
prudent ouais merci Monsieur Jean
Masséna moi j'en ajoute juste une petite
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur mais ça n'est pas
une question c'est simplement sur sur le
volet de progression de la transition
écologique et de l'adaptation
environnementale et un sujet qui
commence à être très très prégnant et
qui est pris vraiment au sérieux par
tous les territoires en France c'est
encore d'un coloc récemment qui est
celui de l'eau et de la ressource en eau
qui à mon avis commence était vu à
l'échelle départementale est aujourd'hui
vu à l'échelle nationale et à mon avis
il y a vraiment un enjeu européen aussi
sur cette question là
merci
excellence en ce qui concerne donc la
révision du marché de l'électricité donc
l'Espagne s'est distingué parce qu'on a
appelé le modèle ibérique donc je
voulais savoir un peu quelle était la
position maintenant officielle de de
l'Espagne dans le cadre de ses futurs
négociations qui vont s'ouvrir justement
pour réformer le marché d'électricité
bon merci pour la question je vais
essayer de répondre et
un quart d'heure très rapidement et
alors il y a quelques points qui sont
très spécifiques à peut-être je n'ai
l'information maintenant je pourrais
vous
informer après par écrit sur certains
sujets pour laisser plus de temps pour
les autres sujets dans desquels je peux
je peux dire quelque chose de plus
intéressant j'imagine bon
si on commence
la première question c'était de la
leucléaire oui
bon comme vous savez et on a on a fait
la négociation pendant les précédentes
suédoises on a parlé beaucoup de ça au
Conseil européen
parfois on a considéré qu'il y avait
deux groupes d'États États qui étaient
plus
ferme concernant ce qu'on appelle les
énergies vertes sans faire distension
entre les nécessaires à bacarbonne
d'autre part il y avait d'autres pays
comme la France qui considèrent que le
bacaron était aussi et une énergie qui
méritait être considérée presque verte
c'est à dire qu'une énergie pas
renouvelable mais une énergie d'avenir
de futurs qui devait faire aussi et par
différents
de la taxonomie européenne et c'est une
négociations a été importante je crois
qu'on est arrivé on est arrivé à des
accords importants à l'équilibre pour
nous pour l'Espagne en tant que état
nous comprenons bien que la France a
pris des décisions pour le nucléaire et
qui a une source d'énergie
en préférence que c'est le nucléaire on
prend qu'on prend ça on ne veut pas
aller tout ça on ne peut pas faire comme
ça on doit tenir compte les intérêts de
tous les pays les problèmes étaient à
l'époque que on ne pouvait considérer de
notre peur que le nucléaire était une
énergie verte complément renouvelable
parce qu'il y avait le sujet de déchets
etc alors qu'il fallait faire une petite
différence on a trouvé la manière de le
faire d'une part de la part de la
Commission à travailler bien dans ce
sujet et on a travaillé bien avec la
France avec les autres États membres je
crois qu'on est arrivé on est arrivé en
accord important et de la part de je
vais vous dire que l'Espagne a
compressidance va va faire un effort
avec tous les pays avec tous les
sensibilités on comprend très bien la
sensibilité française dans ce sujet on a
parlé beaucoup au plus haut niveau et
sur ces dans ce domaine et je crois que
maintenant on est déjà dans la grande
ligne
quelle était la cause de notre réflexion
c'était que on ne pouvait pas établir
une parallèle complet entre le nucléaire
le reste et l'allergie verte parce que
alors on découragé d'une certaine façon
tous les fois de transition écologique
qu'on demande des pour d'autres États
membres on ne pouvait pas dire
simplement que les tous l'énergie à bac
avant on était semblable parce que là on
pouvait regretter en train de décourager
d'autres pays qui faisaient dans les
forts importants des financement pour le
changement et la transition écologique
c'était ça pour défendre un peu les
renouvelables ce que le Nouvel An était
comme une alternative pour l'Europe de
l'avenir mais cela n'avait rien contre
la position française et on a trouvé des
accords à trouver un équilibre je crois
très important pour pour l'Europe et
cela concernant le nucléaire après il y
a l'élargissement les sujets de la
Géorgie je vous ai dit que pour
l'élargissement on atteindre les
rapports de la commission c'est la
Commission qui va nous dire quel état
sont préparés pour aller de l'avant et
quelles autres doivent encore rester et
en faisant des réformes en faisant un
parcours plus lent alors sans ça on ne
peut pas se poser une position avoir une
position sur la Géorgie ou sur d'autres
États évidemment dans tout ce qui
concerne les ragissements c'est la
n'échappe à personne il y a un élément
politique
ça a été aussi le cas pendant
largement des années 2000 avec les pays
de l'Europe de l'Est il avait une
urgence politique bien sûr mais on doit
maintenir en équilibre entre l'urgence
politique le symbole politique les
messages qu'on fait passer à ces
communautés c'est nations et d'autre
part la version qu'on a des des garantir
une addition cohérente
et cela se fait avec l'esprit c'est fait
avec le travail dans les diverses
chapitres et une chose ce n'est mais ne
supprime pas l'autre c'est ça doit aller
de la main laissant les autres spéc je
crois que c'est important de souligner
ça mais nous sommes sur la contrainte de
politique bien sûr en ce qui concerne
les Ukraine bien sûr
alors on va trouver aussi un équilibre
en latence que la Commission va nous
dire mais ce que je peux vous dire de la
part de l'Espagne comme Président on
suivra la Commission on comprendra les
aspects politiques mais en même temps on
fait passer un
message très clair qu'on doit
approfondir les aspects techniques la
démocratisation de la société
l'adaptation de l'économie des
institutions de judiciaire la lutte
contre la corruption tout cela qui est
essentiel pour l'Europe de l'avenir on
ne peut pas dire l'Europe sur des
fondements faibles
et il y a après les multinationales
c'est un sujet que je ne connais pas je
sais que c'est un sujet important mais
je vais renseigner et vous à dire
quelque chose après parce que je ne
connais pas exactement quel est notre
position que va on va suivre j'imagine
la commission tous les projets de la
commission mais en général nous sommes
évidemment nous considère que nos
besoins de ressources parce qu'il y a
maintenant des projets solaires dans
l'autonomiste stratégique et on a besoin
de plus de ressources européennes alors
ce que je ne sais pas je ne peux pas
vous dire si la multinationale est taxe
sur les multinationales vont être faire
partie d'une association de cette façon
de l'autre quelle est la position de la
pression espagnole
et sur Marco soul il y a eu beaucoup de
questions sur un sujet très très
intéressant très important parce que
fait combine des aspects et géopolitique
d'intérêts haricots sociales et ce sont
des aspects que l'Espagne et la France
pour partager très clairement parce que
on a une population en agriculteurs très
sensible tous ces sujets alors et nous
comprenons très bien la position de la
France nous comprenons très bien les
soucis de s'agriculteurs nous savons
qu'on ne peut être établir un système de
double standard pour les importations
qui viennent d'autres pays tels que le
pays latine et le travail des
agriculteurs chez nous
et alors nous sommes derrière la
commission avec ce document qu'elle nous
a présenté et
d'approfondir les aspects
environnemental etc
ce que nous vous disons et c'est clair
c'est qu'on ne peut attendre tout pour
toujours ça on doit travailler on doit
trouver des solutions on doit s'asseoir
autour d'une table et parler avec les
états de la mairie de latine
nous savons et on le sait bien que même
à la mairie de latine il y a des
possessions différenciées et que le
président Loula peut être il voudrait
renégocier quelques aspects de la de
l'accord alors on peut le faire on peut
commencer déjà on attend une réponse de
sa part mais le point c'est que on ne
peut dire simplement non on ne peut
simplement dire cela est très sensible
pour nous pour les agriculteurs pour
notre société il y a un double standard
qu'on ne peut pas accepter et on laisse
ça de côté pour une année de trois
quatre je crois qu'on ne peut pas faire
ça dans la géopolitique le temps avant
c'est très rapidement maintenant tous
les décisions doit être prises dans suce
une perspective et stratégique et alors
ce que la guerre d'ukrain de la pandémie
nous a montré ce que l'Europe doit faire
face aux défis doit faire face aux défis
immédiatement alors ce que nous
proposons dans cette ce sommet des chefs
d'État du gouvernement à Bruxelles et
c'est des 18 18 c'est pas about d'accord
si on peut vous dire la rose ça c'est
magnifique mais surtout le plus
important c'est d'avoir conscience de
l'importance cet accord d'avoir
conscience tout autour de la table qu'il
faut faire en chemin comment on fait les
routes au moins on doit sortir des
sommets avec une feuille de route avec
un mandat pour négocier dans une dans
quelques étapes pendant notre présidence
peut-être dans la présidence prochaine
mais il doit avoir une échéance on ne
peut pas laisser le sujet éternellement
sans solution parce que ça va contre
l'ouverture le marché ouvert comment
qu'on demande ça va contre les intérêts
géopolitiques on ne peut voir regarder
passivement comment dans la mairie
latine d'autres acteurs sans aucune
limite entre et commence à prendre des
des
des rapports
et sustentiels dans quelques domaines de
telle les matières premières
essentiel pour l'économie et l'éthologie
prochaine
et je ne sais pas s'il y a d'autres
points je sais que nous sommes un peu
pour les Kosovo vous savez la possession
pour les Kosovo et c'est rapide vous
connaissez bien la position de l'Espagne
l'Espagne pour le moment ne reconnaît
pas les Kosovo et
mais en même temps nous favorisons les
rapports entre la Serbie et le Kosovo
nous sont très proches de l'Union
européenne tous ceux qui concerne les
stabilité de la région pour nous les
vacances bientôt c'est une région
essentielle pour l'Europe on l'a dit
souvent alors une chose ne va pas contre
l'autre mais pour la sécurité c'est la
reconnaissance du Kosovo rien n'a changé
pour le moment je ne peux pas vous
avancer en changement parce que on va
exercer la présidence laissant un peu de
côté nos intérêts nationaux évidemment
on va faire toujours toujours on fait
comme ça la présidente doit être patient
européenne mais évidemment notre
délégation dans les rencontres va
maintenir la position nationale sur la
reconnaissance des Kosovo ça ne va pas
chercher
[Musique]
pharmaceutique et sur les sous de la
pharmacie c'est très important pour nous
la santé après la pandémie on a vu qu'il
avait une dépendance en matière
sanitaire qu'il restait beaucoup à faire
on a fait très bien on a consolider une
politique européenne très rapidement on
a c'est une des éléments qui nous fait
nous rend plus fier de l'Europe et qui a
renforcé notre capacité et notre
autostime sur ce qu'il a le repère
centre aujourd'hui la réaction à la
pandémie mais il reste beaucoup à faire
dans la santé c'est pourquoi nous savons
mais la santé
en top des priorités des des notre
président et la tonneau stratégique nous
ne la comprenons pas simplement comme
une autonomie de sécurité mais comme une
autonomie dans la santé dans le sujet
santé alors tous ceux qui comportent la
santé qui concerne la santé comme les
médicaments tout ça c'est une priorité
pour nous alors nous allons faire avec
la commission
de notre mieux pour avancer dans ce
domaine
il est autre sujet sur
européen mais en Espagne c'est un sujet
très important les tribunaux reconnus et
la circularité des des travailleurs et
l'aspect rigide et la protection de ce
travail était un point de départ
politique en Espagne très fort du
gouvernement espagnol alors évidemment
si on fait ça à l'intérieur évidemment
vous réfère de pareil à l'extérieur en
Europe parce que c'est un point faible
un point faible de la sécurité sociale
renforcement de l'emploi secure et on
aura et alors on est à une situation de
détresse et ce sont des jeunes qui qui
travaillent dans ces plateformes on a vu
récemment en France les problèmes de la
jeunesse alors il faut travailler
beaucoup projet social en ces aspects je
n'ai pas entré dans le sujet social
parce que c'est très il y a beaucoup de
points mais je peux vous dire que tous
les points sociaux vont devenir un
élément essentiel de notre de notre
président surtout parce qu'on ne peut
croire on peut comprendre l'Europe sans
les social parce que quand on parle de
nos proches des citoyens on parle du
social bien sûr des médicaments on
parlait de la plate des plateformes ce
qu'on voit les citoyens au jour les
jours les problèmes et les plus proches
on parle de l'emploi on parle aussi dans
les cadres financiers de la capacité
d'avoir plus de flexibilité pour faire
des dépenses dans le social si on a une
instabilité une austérité très très
serrée on aura moins de possibilités de
faire ses dépenses et de faire une
croissance et en équilibre c'est quoi ça
économique sociale les multinationales
mais en même temps nos travailleurs bien
sûr
merci
bien sûr